[Music]
Comcast 54 seconds of logos reading also
president Hillary Clinton really turned
that unemployment figure around didn't
she
amazing she signed off on the purge act
that must have been some pork added by
Senator Charles Manson discount
beatitudes
wait a minute it's the night of the
purge and there's just some random dude
checking his phone out in the open what
a dumbass movie borrows its premise from
a night of losing hockey in Vancouver
I mean seriously some of these scenarios
where people are getting murdered are
ridiculous hey Bert tonight I'm gonna go
get some work done at the office
oops wrong move Tony from sales hates
you clearly more people will be purging
this year than ever before well there
must be a lot of supermodels in the new
founding father future nobody's
bothering us tonight that's another
thing how many people truly purge
themselves by killing homeless people I
know that's the movies point the
powerless are being eradicated but
mainly people want to kill that guy who
cut them off in traffic or farted in the
elevator but those people can probably
afford good security systems Lena Headey
isn't my fault sister in this scene
awards for writing softball and
gymnastics this is an orgy of evidence
that perfect daughter is perfect also
school uniforms that are this sexy are a
sin against American society and men and
women and everyone and my penis this
boyfriend is not obviously up to no good
because I've never seen a movie before
for dramatic movie purposes this asshole
dragged has blade sharpening device all
the way out into the middle of the
backyard to sharpen this machete here
Selena Gomez is rocking Times Square
tonight son likes to look up his own
mother skirt and I'm okay with that and
I am NOT okay with that well you let him
keep a chart baby doll with a camera in
it
I think creeping is the most minor thing
your son does also this is apparently
Sid from Toy Story only a much nicer kid
child draws scary images in a horror
movie cliche son has a secret hiding
room because that will become important
to the plot later someone's suddenly
behind the open refrigerator door cliche
ethan hawke went from no light at dinner
and sinister to light everywhere in the
purge hell there are five lamps just in
this one angle yeah I mean all kids in
movies they can't just be normal right
asthma night terrors heart problems the
kids are not alright is Hollywood just
letting actual kids write the angry
teenager dialog
days is that what's going on here
dormitorium movie tries to sneak this
videos dumbed online in movie history by
us with a little group laughter alright
time for lockdown why didn't you just
lockdown earlier were you expecting
guests oh it's just a precaution okay so
far this movie is the assault on
precinct 13 remake without the cop stuff
and that is not really a good thing I
know she thinks she looks good but she's
kept her school uniform on through
dinner and is now going to wear it all
night for the purge - wow you're just
now locking down but clock showed us it
was 655 and you came in here and watched
your surveillance cameras check your
guns anyone wanted to kill you you'd be
dead already
in fact why don't people take advantage
of those precious minutes before the
purge reficul e begins and after it
officially ends unless you're out in the
open getting caught by security cameras
who would know if it happened during the
purge or not the next day has to be like
a holiday right how many people have to
go to work the next day after a purge
who could sleep during this I'd be a lot
of dead people your workplace - and I am
NOT coming in on a Saturday - play
catch-up
I have to admit an emergency broadcast
bulletin is one of the cutest ways I've
ever seen exposition jam down my throat
I wanted to surprise you so nice so now
we find out why they didn't just go to
the lockdown right away because this
asshole needed to get into the house
somehow seriously if you're in a world
that allows the purge don't you lock
down immediately for this very reason
also how did he sneak in in addition to
not locking down they just left doors
and windows open and this Charlie kid
needs to be purged someway somehow
tonight I mean it's legal right what an
asshole this kid is the purge is the one
night a year when people get that
long-awaited release
student before any major decision you
have sex first that ensures at the very
least you have sex before anything
stupid happens to prevent you from
having it also this dude thinks that
killing her dad is gonna make everything
okay what is this natural-born killers
Jesus is all this movies exposition
delivered by television also just no one
ever do bad things for 364 days out of
the year never because they get one
killing Christmas and she really hates
that wig doesn't she so here's this
homeless dude I'd like to know how he
ran away from people trying to kill him
into this gated community and remember
this neighborhood is kind of out of the
way in the first place no movie you hold
on damn these two have been discussing
this before forever they were talking
about it back when the mom was still
working out and since then she's got a
shower changed worried about violence
with her husband the kids been snooping
around and they are just now getting
ready to come out and speak to the
father well my boyfriend is about to go
talk to my dad about us being together
it's purge night time to listen to some
tunes 26 minutes in I can safely say
that this is the worst kid ever in film
I'll somehow explain this to my dad
after we're done choking on our own
blood in the kitchen she's how big is
this front yard anyway where's this
asshole been the whole time mr. Sandin
I'd like to announce my presence before
killing you I want to get enraged that
the daughter just saw her boyfriend try
to murder her dad but it's still trying
to save the boyfriend but honestly I can
kind of see her panties also the
daughter just saw her boyfriend tried to
murder her dad but is still trying to
save the boyfriend with that man
Ethan Hawke is the smartest character in
this movie I can't believe I just said
that here's a special game called Ethan
Hawke never notices people behind him in
horror movies
I mean it's mr. boogie somewhere around
here man these people are way behind the
guy they want to kill how do they even
know he's around here inside the room
are you waiting for also just say there
are people shooting guns and walking
down the street they look angry
what's with this mom this kid drives a
charred baby camera around the house and
is an asshole
spit it out Junior you need to see this
cliche now Zoey just disappears in the
house somehow never to be seen until the
plant needs her again oh good Twilight
characters
no one's saying something Thanks several
live near dear neighbors informed us
they did not you asshole you were
walking up the street and seconds later
you were on his lawn calling him out
gone killing one of us when we attempted
to execute him tonight you have like
seven people in your group how did he
kill one of you first and still get away
the freaks got the power for no reason
other than to make the house and this
movie darker and cause unnecessary
complications seriously why they do this
also with the power out how can these
freaks expect James to disarm the
security system to let the homeless guy
out so they can kill it come on Rebecca
as monitors do things like this are not
supposed to happen oh my god is this guy
really the main character the
protagonist I can't really relate to his
money based racism or his wife's
worrywart demeanor both kids are fucking
assholes and stupid who am I supposed to
be rooting for here we have guns
how do you know didn't the polite
leaders say the guy killed one of them
was it with his bare hands did they sit
around watching while the homeless dude
choked the life out of one of their
purge siblings jumpy noises are we sure
this isn't sinister did Ian Hawke
accidentally sign up for two movies
after thinking he read the same single
script twice what the is a plan here
let's both go out separately with
flashlights and leave our kid alone and
unguarded honestly to be as good a
Salesman as this guy's been made out to
be you have to have some intelligence
kissing condoms whoa this Ethan Hawke
horror movie actually just turned into
sinister here how big is this place you
mean two people walking around the house
can't see the flashing lights of the
demonic camera car baby I'll follow you
anywhere a remote-controlled Satan I
really need to tell you something that
you already know bad guys aren't bad
guys unless they constantly insert
insults into sentences no matter how
clunky it makes them sound I just can't
find him and that's all James says about
the guy most people might remark it's
dark in here this place is huge and he's
hiding and could be dangerous
why did you turn off the lights of
course you are you went missing for 15
minutes of this movie for no other
reason okay you can't do this cheaters
you have well established that the
daughter is a scream bot you can't then
say she opened the secret chamber with a
gun and was disarmed and subdued by a
guy with a knife without one single
scream or sound that the entire house
would he
and that's not even mentioning the Sun
who decides that saving the homeless man
is still more important than anything
and worth creating a sister life for so
he also doesn't scream or yell anything
flashlight assistant Mexican standoff
not a big fan of shaky cam but its way
the hell better than whatever the fuck
this call
lifted him up and get him outside
because we need more time to reflect on
this moral dilemma we have in front of
us we could easily just drag him to the
front door while he's unconscious and
hurt but sure let's tie him up first
what is the moral lesson here that
people will turn into animals when other
people break into their home and
threaten to kill them that's not a
terrible thing really is it are we
really supposed to be feeling any moral
quandary about the decision to sacrifice
the homeless man and save their family
cuz I'm not least you need to work on
their communication skills that was
obviously a stab and not a press on his
wound and he's got dog tags I mean the
guy is a former soldier check his pocket
he's probably an organ donor too oh and
look at this he also volunteers at the
homeless shelter even though he too is
homeless this is the first good thing
we've seen our protagonists do this
entire movie so much soda that feels
completely unnatural and not earned know
your business are you even in this
family anymore we're gonna fight hell
yeah this movies about to go home alone
on your ass wait man this dude's head
turned timing is either completely
terrible or absolutely fucking perfect
after deciding to let him live and the
two even coming to an agreement on the
logic of the situation they still let
this do tied up and didn't give him a
gun to help kick ass at least assault on
precinct 13 let the prisoners have a
chance to help defend themselves
seriously the way this house has been
mapped out in the film who cares where
the bad guys are we have no idea where
the rooms are where they are in relation
to each other the whole house is just a
jangled mess of close-ups in the dark
with no context
whatever purging also requires dragging
your victim to a special place so that
someone can save him later Xzibit ur ex
machina this house is either so huge the
gunshots aren't heard throughout or
these kill loving murderers are stupid
for not all running to the sound of the
gunshots in the basement so you're
telling me not one person is hiding in
the totally not findable secret hiding
wall spawned in the boys bedroom phew
see by the bad guy man I don't know her
dad's got a thing about her dating older
guys guy in the background definitely
saw where dreams went when he walked in
the kitchen but the science' stupidly
walk in like he has no idea about
anything even his own name also this is
the first time ethan hawke has ever
noticed a guy in the background in one
of these movies getting his ass beat
finds random hard object abash attackers
head in with cliche how does this guy
know to smash through this window and
why do these bad guys keep coming one by
one Wow okay so two cliches at work here
at once the guy turns and steps into a
stabbing cliche and the evil guy who
just stabbed someone has excellent and
gentle bedside manner after the deed
cliche take your pick
man the asshole silently stalking her
has been doing so since the very moment
the home invasion began he obviously has
no interest in killing that or the
writer was just trying to play fast and
loose so the action sequences could
appear in the right order
even though Mary was not making any
noise this lady freak knew when to jump
scare at the precise time or she was
just jumping out of the room for the
past five minutes and finally got lucky
well I was unexpected not the ex machina
part but the daughter part where did the
gun happy neighbors go why could they
systematically kill all the freak
burgers except the main one what she was
standing there and the dude didn't see
her coming q for fuck's sake
[Music]
isn't that what you're gonna do anyway
your barricades came down for to cleanse
ourselves of her hatred it seems like if
rich neighbors wanted to kill a slightly
richer neighbor on a legal night to do
so they could have found a way to do it
that didn't rely on pure dumb luck
purging also requires saying a blessing
God will be pleased you didn't murder a
family without ceremony
the homeless guy found Charlie's RC
burned peeping baby and decided I'll use
this as a distraction first because my
suprise entrance will be stupider that
way
did you enjoy Grace's purge party mr.
Halverson female protagonist who once
peace decides to needle her neighbors
with one more minute of purge time left
okay so she's dead right or if movies
have taught me anything she's gonna wake
up surrounded by people who want to
learn her secrets before they kill her
two remaining protagonists don't fall in
love and live happily ever after that's
hard for me to swallow it's fantastic
[Music]
look at me Mary this is our kids live
here anybody tries to come in your blast
them he will not hesitate I will not
hesitate not for a second
they're coming to take you this will not
be over quickly they will not enjoy this
I am Not sure you're in pain perhaps
it's time to go home when you play the
game of Thrones you win
will you die
there is no middle ground